[Música]
se han dado cuenta de cómo a nosotros
las palabras nos pueden incomodar las
palabras nos pueden hacer sentir mal nos
pueden molestar nos pueden como a sacar
escozor dar comezón y hasta mandar a la
chica de eso vamos a hablar ahora las
palabras las palabras tienen poder es
cómo resuena una palabra en tu mente
cuántas veces no hemos soñado con una
palabra con una idea por ejemplo quién
tiene un apodo aquí hace la mano quien
tiene una por ivette mucho error ahora
quien ha puesto un apodo
a que la
qué pasa con los apodos los apodos son a
veces bonitos no oye
lucecita qué bonito pero si te dicen el
salmón como le decíamos a un amigo de la
facultad porque viví en ecatepec
nosotros quedamos en seo y venía de muy
lejos echar la hueva
es el cuate obviamente cada vez se
volvió más huevo y por qué pues no
quería hacer nada no un amigo mío que le
hicimos el pulque porque es blanco y
baboso no es va por la vida no hay
luciendo su estrechez y su blancura no y
sintiéndose mal por su apodo iba por ahí
con ese cono de la vergüenza no que es
su apodo y que me dicen de otra cosa que
es súper súper molestan los
hipocorísticos los hipocorísticos no son
apodos propiamente pero son formas
cariñosas de decirnos a nosotros no
entonces por ejemplo mi novio que se
llama jose enrique o díaz que le digan
pp pero además es automático como éstas
josé conté además josé a yola pp pour
cuando dije pp no producirlo y la peni
la e no y automática mi prima la
directora de algarabía de arte algarabía
victoria automáticamente le ponen vicky
en el star box a nombre de quien de
victoria vicky
nunca dije vicky no dice mi prima que
prefiere que se llama graciela que
prefiere que el ambiente en la favela no
muchos es un nombre bonito jesús acaba
en chucho no entonces si nos damos
cuenta las palabras reflejan muchas
cosas reflejan nuestras envidias
reflejan nuestros miedos reflejan
obviamente lo que decía ahorita rojo la
incomodidad los complejos los atavismos
y hasta nuestras fobias cuando hablamos
estamos reflejando todo eso que les voy
a contar de algunos idiomas donde
existen palabras como work que aquí no
la pudimos traducir que quiere decir
justamente algo incómodo algo como que
no te queda bien algo que no viene al
caso no una situación como enseñar al
nadar a la suegra no lo imagínate no no
sea muy difícil o para entonces por
ejemplo está gas
brooke la pongo en alta porque gas
brooke está en alemán y en alemán con
los atractivos valen alta gasto que
quiere decir la incomodidad de ser un
buen huésped
cuando llegue a casa de alguien muy fino
lis muy fi
y entonces no sabes como si usted va a
sentar bien y si no que le llevo le
lleva un vino no no no le llevo nada
cómo me siento no como mucho por tu mamá
ya te había dicho no desde chiquito que
atacabas todo lo que te deben entonces
ten cuidado entonces ya no sabes cómo
byd todos bailan y cantan y tú no en una
boda no el gas truck en alemán existe la
palabra la incomodidad de ser un buen
invitado o esta palabra que viene del
agua que también refleja más que
incomodidad es el pin a whisky y es una
enfermedad que les da a los awac el mlp
alta entonces les da hoy en día todavía
por avergonzar miento pin a wish le
viene de avergonzar miento y es cuando
alguien te ve por ejemplo desnuda no sin
querer estás bañando te ve a alguien
desnuda un hombre y entonces te empieza
a dar una enfermedad te empieza a doler
la cabeza te empezó a sentir mal incluso
pues te puede dar fiebre y hasta vómito
por ésta
avergonzado que es el piragüista como
cada palabra y cada lengua
conceptualizar diferente o el ipsa por
una palabra que me encanta de la lengua
inuit la lengua inuit está hablada en el
norte eran los famosos esquimales de los
que ya no se les estima les porque es
una forma despectiva se dice esquimal
quiere decir los que comen carne cruda
entonces un pescado crudo entonces son
los inuit y su aporte es esta sensación
de / ansia desesperación y un poquito
también de intensidad cuando alguien
está esperando en un iglú que llegue a
alguien en una gran obviamente explanada
de nieve y sale del iglú y no viene no
ve a nadie y vuelve a entrar y sale del
iglú y bud y usted dicen bueno pues si
solamente lo sienten los esquimales no
no no solamente los inuit nosotros nos
sentimos cuando por ejemplo mandamos un
whatsapp ya tienen las dos palomitas
azules y no nos contestaron no entonces
sentimos insúa porque no de distancia de
por qué no no porque no me porque no me
contesta no ya la vio no o está online y
no te contesta no te pone muy mal y
bueno como les decía o work no que es
esta palabra imposible de traducir son
palabras que cada lengua conceptualiza
de manera diferente y son lost in
translation y está que me encanta que es
el keymare speech también en alta porque
sale mal
la el peso que ganas después de que un
novio te dejo o sea cuando tienes mal de
amores empieza a comer a comer a comer
porque me quiere decir pena y espectrito
sino entonces es como cómo vas creciendo
en tocino por ahí por el helado que te
estás comiendo viendo netflix lloré y
lloré y lloré yo por eso les recomiendo
que mejor mezcal no es más fácil hay
palabras que nos causan incomodidad en
los sentimos fatal con ellas por ejemplo
que me dicen del tenemos que hablar
digan no estás con un nuevo y de repente
dice oye te invitó a cenar porque es que
tenemos que hacer
algo malo va a pasar nuevo
el jefe cierra la puerta a martínez
tenemos que hablar ya te va a correr no
o el empleado no hay pilar puede hablar
contigo es que tenemos que hablar me va
a renunciar no es
es tajante el tenemos que hablar es
tajante y qué me dices del que cree por
ejemplo llegue el ingenio que cree y que
que cree y que se chingó la máquina
siempre es algo malo lo que viene
después de un que cree llegas a tu casa
con la muchacha actriz que cree señora
tu hombre ya no hay gas el niño vomitó o
sea algo malo pasó no el que cree
siempre te va a llevar algo mal y qué me
dicen de este con todo respeto pero a mí
cuando me dicen con todo respeto cierran
los ojos de agua ciudad y no con
todo respeto que mal se te ve esa ropa
con todo respeto como has engordado con
todo respeto este trae el mal aliento
con todo respeto está es un cilantro en
el diente no sea el con todo respeto de
verdad es
es de verdad te la deja ir es horrible y
hay otras palabras que no es que sea la
frase la que te saca de onda sino así
que no es lo que dices martín sino el
ring íntimo o sea si decía mi abuelita o
sea como te lo dice no igual la palabra
en sí misma no es mala pero como te la
dicen por ejemplo llegada a la oficina
tú muy arreglada pintada que te pasa
estás enferma
o sea pero pero luego hasta el baño
igual pero el que te pasa estás enferma
o está que me decían a mí las normas de
la escuela no hay pobre tú no puedes
venir al desayuno como tú trabajas
o sea como yo me siento bien me siento
mal porque si trabajo yo ya no trabajan
y entonces yo soy esta televisión así
como una conmiseración de pobre tú no
puedes como tú trabaja y generalmente
estas cosas lo platicaba que verdad
fuera este están hechas yo no tengo un
libro que se llama el que no me entiende
el de agua camino contra lenguaje
masculino e hizo un estudio ahí y
encontré que el 80 por ciento de esas
frases denostativas como vieja
golfa pendeja buena para nada
etcétera son dichas por otras mujeres el
80% son de mujeres a mujeres y el 20%
restante lo dicen los hombres así que
cuando hablemos de machismo lingüístico
y de sexismo en la lengua pues culpemos
más a las mujeres que a los hombres
aunque ese es otro tema una cosa que es
horrible y que también nos ha sentido
work es el manso training sino redoblar
df terminó este término fue acuñado
apenas en 2014 y entró al diccionario de
oxford por rebecca solnit que es una
periodista y ella es como libro se llama
los hombres lo explican cosas que yo ya
sé
qué tal imanes playing de los hombres es
increíble él por ejemplo oye si quieres
estaciónate en baterías y sabes cómo se
estaciona en batería no
si oyes y vas a agarrar el segundo piso
necesita estar
o no oye es que la llanta a mirar atrás
y hay una cosa en una posición
o sea todos lo sabemos pero ellos tienen
esa necesidad de paternidad y de ser el
más playing explicarnos que no se les
hace la mano aquí quien les ha tenido
más de las mujeres que les ha tocado un
hombre que les haga más play es de todos
desde la vida completa el más pleno y
más explican cosas que dices no puedes
ser de verdad no puede ser oye a mí no
también 14 oye porque no tratan de
vender más publicidad para la revista no
no se me ha ocurrido crist a la razón
pero ellos se queda también está el fair
play inning el fair play
porque ustedes pensaron que yo iba a
estar contra los hombres pero no también
las mujeres tenemos lo nuestro el tip la
típica mujer que deja al bebé le dice mi
amor si se hace por lo cambias no
o sea como si él no fuera papá del niño
también no no
este llevo para poner poner a calentar
la sopa nada más se mueve le tan dichosa
que está en esto pero azul el sobre azul
que ésta no sea
ahora algunas otras palabras más que
incomodidad son hasta repulsivas y ahí
les dan algunas verrugas
esa no es porque sea la palabra
simplemente lo que refiere es feo una
verruga porque oye mira te voy a enseñar
mi verrugas no como que no sino que
además la palabra verruga entre la ere
la ave lage es fea no como barriga
también la imagen tacto con tu novio que
te dijera que linda tu barriguita mi
amor nos ha como que no y otras que
tratan como debe ser buena onda no o sea
cómo te tratan como de no quiero decir
voy a ir a entonces voy a clonar
me no por favor
no voy a liberar a willy no
voy a hacer del 1 del 2 no
voy a pipí pintarme y a poco volver
menos no por favor
echar pata esa no la soporto de verdad
de verdad echar es para no tener decir
el acto sexual voy a tener sexo voy a
no echar pata sale peor no te
molesta más entonces repito la palabra
como les digo refleja la envidia el
dolor el odio y la mala leche también lo
refleja todo y aquí vemos algunas
maldiciones que son en lengua yiddish
que es una lengua hablada por los judíos
una lengua portátil sobre todo los
curiosas que nacen más venados las
prostitutas que nace en europa y es una
lengua que mete palabras del hebreo con
palabras del alemán pero yo tiene unas
maldiciones muy interesantes que
justamente reflejan todo este dolor
imagínate esto que lo peguen contra la
pared como un almanaque y que cada día
la arranca en un pedazo
que te des en eso o no que sea muy rico
pero el único rico de todas sus familias
es horrible no soy mi papá aquí será que
todos mis amigos fueran ricos para que
papi para que te des no para que no me
pidan que no
que dios le mandé un estúpido y nunca se
lo pueda sacar de encima a la gente un
aquí todo el tiempo junto de ti
no no dicen que dios mío mándame
penn de dolor mándame males añejos pero
lidiar con no me lo mande señor
no
y que te estás preciosa que tengo un
negocio enorme repleto de mercancía y
que no le pidan nada de lo que tenga y
ni tenga nada de lo que le pida
o sea no puede ser más gente no
que se traiga paraguas y se le abra en
el vientre
que como como un caballo y que como
pájaros
pero lo que también es interesante es
que las palabras que más nos molestan
son las que nos decimos a nosotros
mismos o porque la vamos acarreando
nuestros papás porque dijeron alguien
cuando éramos chiquitos son porque lo
hicieron en la escuela no por ejemplo yo
en el 'stand' gordísima no manches no
es un cerdo en el espejo esa es
para mí tajante y me ha la vida
no está por ejemplo nunca vas a poder
trabajar en tener hijos a la vez es esa
idea de las mujeres de cómo lo voy a
hacer con las dos cosas que sí es
bastante complejo pero que se puede
mantener camino y que tel aviv es porque
relación desde chiquita porque tlc tu
mamá porque la tía carmelitano rutas
tener una casa propia mira esas ojeras o
sea esas palabras que los auto decimos
no que son tan no nunca vas a tener una
empresa cultural que te dé dinero o sea
nunca una empresa de cultura puede dar
dinero es algo que yo me repetí muchas
veces y que obviamente caló hondo hasta
que de repente
lo que haces es des colocarte no porque
las palabras tanto buenas como malas
escalan y entonces para que dejen de
calar hay que justamente quitarles el
significado primeros a veces son tuyas o
no son tuyas a ver esta frase ve nunca
voy a poder trabajar y tener hijos es
mía o es que me la dijo mi mamá la dijo
la abuelita o la dijo la tía no que
quien la dijo quién me la dijo cómo me
la me tienen cerebro y como la po sacar
las palabras de cana y si no las la
resonancia no y cuando empieces a
quitarte las no dice saber esto no tiene
ningún sentido claro que se puede ver
ejemplos de cosas que se puedan y
evidentemente cambias el verbo no y le
quitas el adverbio no y le pones se
puede se puede trabajar y tener hijos no
y le das su justo valor en ese momento
cuando yo me di cuenta que si podía
trabajar y tener hijos que si pueda
tener una empresa cultura como algarabía
que me dé dinero y con la que pueda
vivir que si podía no
adelgazar que no podía tener que ser la
que siempre estaba enferma entonces
empieza a cambiar el discurso y empiezas
a tener todo le vas dando su justo valor
las palabras al final del camino son
formas son fonemas son sonidos son
nuestras y nosotros tenemos que ser con
ellas más que nosotros debemos hacer
como les digo cada lengua tiene su forma
de ser
el mexicano cuando dice si se puede
evidentemente ya está implicando que no
se podía antes no no hay que decir nunca
esa frase de si se puede porque ya
implica que no se podía muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]